huh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  wow  [Applause]  [Applause]  so  [Applause]  so  roller  oh  [Applause]  [Applause]  huh  [Music]  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  it actually broke  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  [Applause]  um  [Applause]  wow  i got  it oh  [Applause]  [Applause]  oh  uh  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  come on  [Applause]  [Applause]  so  [Applause]  yo  nice  oh  [Applause]  [Applause]  more  [Applause]  yo  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  [Applause]  i feel like a kangaroo  oh  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  so  come on  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  hey  [Applause]  so there is still 72 of you guys who  haven't subscribed to our channel so  remember to do that now and we have just  updated our mobile game download it for  free in the links in the description  until next time  [Applause]